[Music]
hey Conan O'Brien here with another
episode of clueless gamer this is where
I rate video games which is ironic
because I don't play them well I have no
experience with them I don't even really
enjoy them but who better than me today
Tomb Raider and help me out as always as
my friend mr. Aaron Blair hello
so Tomb Raider follows The Chronicles of
its its Lara Croft yes let it okay this
is my first complaint it should be Lara
you want to say Laura everybody wants to
say Laura and everybody does say Laura
secretly but somewhere along the line
some prick was like Noah Ryan a famous
explorer once said it's kind of a
trailer for the game okay you're gonna
talk through it yes
to make my mom oh oh she's very
attractive
there's the [ __ ] I know that's a [ __ ]
okay she died wait a minute what
happened she got pulled out but there's
ruff that's Rob whoa that was an
incredible lick Oh Roth drops her and
he's looking at her cleaner yes Roth
dropped her so he could look at her
cleavage we totally had her and he was
like I'd like to take a look Wow
actually let us use this awesome limited
edition control this is a limited
edition controller it's made of a very
expensive marzipan this can be eaten
this is the beginning a what a cool
thing about this game is it has a
dynamic camera so it looks a lot like a
movie it's very cinematic oh so it's not
her point of view we actually get to
look at her
yes very smart decision square-enix
otherwise I'm the man in a woman's body
you know as opposed to what I really am
which is a woman trapped in a man's body
[Music]
you know what that is not her first
piercing jeez get on there piercing
pressing back yes all right let's get
out yeah let's get out those are tight
pants and I'm a guy that's right behind
her
what's up save that person that's
another girl you know what in real life
a girl would think that's competition I
want to help her I really do well she's
dead and she did I think so how do you
know she's dead I mean she looks dead
and there's why I look bad to mangy and
you know what plenty of times that scene
flies around you and you're not dead
okay so we can light this stuff on fire
yeah that's a good idea
that's my instinct when trapping a
confined space just write everything on
fire continues perfect
left's a great move back and forth this
yes what's she swearing
I was trying to drag you to your death
is she holding her side cuz she's
wounded or is she trying to look thinner
need to steep the cake so just run
towards the light yeah that's what I
tell every old person they see remember
go to a nursing home
all I do is shout run towards the light
gonna sort it out by security whoa jump
jump free free yeah awesome
keep running keep running out out yes
right you drive to learn about jump
across that chasm there its chasm did
you say chasm no it's it's azzam this is
it's a CH that's crazy
what a shame
[Applause]
there we go they just climb up the plane
they're just looking at it for this game
of genius because you have an organic
reason to always be it's kind of behind
her and close how do I climb just oh my
god stuff falls apart a lot on this
island hey you know what island we're on
lawsuit island he must have come this
way wait look at this she found a
handbag and she's distracted okay we
have now jumped ahead in the game and
I've been asked to tone it down with the
pervy stuff so now we find ourselves
trapped in this monastery you've been
captured and here we go
I'm so perving out sorry I think someone
should call the police
oh okay let's get out of here sorry
fellas I tunes what did you just say I
hate tombs yeah guess what then don't be
a tumor
press the red button press the red one
okay now don't hit the trees got a
little blood on you unless those are
berries on the trees get some tree
berries okay here may then we're gonna
go across this river to the right to the
right to the right to the left
[Applause]
all right go to the right okay to the
left to the right
Oh
Oh whoops whoops
[Applause]
Tomb Raider comes out March 5th and I
have to tell you it is an incredible
game graphics amazing the action and
good god Lara let's face it her name is
Laura is incredibly attractive and this
game makes you fall in love with her and
then lose her so this was like high
school all over love the game I've got
to rate it now if this right here is bad
if this is good I'm gonna give it up
[Applause]